hey richard what's up can you hear me
what's happening it says here in your
message when a female friend invites you
to travel alone
what does that mean yeah the thing is
that well i have a friend
um which i met for somewhat some months
ago
and she basically told me to go travel
together
and meaning meaning she wants you to pay
for the trip
no no like uh no like everyone ever each
one pays
their own part and yeah we agreed on
that
but the thing is that uh
um yeah i would like to know if that's
like
something like a friend will do it or
it's
that means something you know when you
say
friend like are you banging like is she
just a friend that you play cards with
like um
oh uh well she's actually a friend that
we
rehearse uh many times like
i met her last year on september
and yeah and she saw on the book
we made a good relationship out of us
ourselves and now she told me to travel
to the north of the country and
i'm like hey like you haven't answered
my question though yet like have you
been intimate with her no
not really because i i see her just
as a friend okay like i think
you want to be intimate with her i
wouldn't mind really
but the thing is that um i should expect
like a
casual friend relationship or like she
wants
so okay so what you're trying to do is
you're is you're trying to
get into her pants by being her friend
like you're trying to friend zone your
way
into the bedroom and this is a common
mistake a lot of guys make
right you can't you can't turn a
friendship into an intimacy
right it just it just doesn't work that
way you know
like women have boyfriends and
girlfriends and if you're not being
intimate with her then you're her
girlfriend
so when she's talking about hey let's
take a trip together
you're going to go and take a trip with
her you're going to be paying for stuff
i don't know if you're going to pay for
her ticket or pay for part of the trip
or buy her
dinner drinks or whatever and she's
going to go off and bang some chad that
she meets
on the vacation and you're going to be
sobbing in your room wondering why
you're not getting
any of the action that you were hoping
that you were going to get you have to
be very very clear with women from the
get-go if you want to be intimate with
them
you have to tell them straight up um
there's a book alan roger
curry wrote called mode one go read that
because that
because that makes it very very clear
the difference between sexual attention
and non-sexual attention
and what you're doing is you're giving
her all this free validation
and you know attention and she's
basically
you know going to use you to go on this
trip like how much of this trip
are you planning on paying for like how
does that break down for you
uh the thing is that we plan to meet
there like
she's a was on vacation with her family
in another part of the north and
she told me like i am i mean with them
but
if you want we can travel together like
we joke about
traveling and then but the things that
i'm not paying for
her anything like she's paying for it no
no don't don't
don't travel with women like
if if she's your sister if she's your
cousin then i'd say
okay you know travel but it if she's a
chick that you want to be intimate with
which you've already indicated that she
is
don't don't try to friend zone your way
into her life right like
put some distance between her if you
want to be intimate with her just tell
her straight up
right you know you tell her from the
get-go you don't play the friend zone
card because that's not going to get you
late
that just gets guys frustrated how old
are you franco
i'm 26 right how many women have you
been with
um i could say
more than 10 yeah more than 10. and you
haven't learned this lesson that the
friend zone doesn't work yet
yeah the thing is that no no yeah of
course i know
relationship between men and women are
like basically can be
friends really no men and women can't be
friends
men and women don't have anything in
common okay aside from
sex and relationships and raising
children what do you have in common
you know with women i like to shoot guns
i like fast cars
you know these are the things that i
like there's nothing that like there's
there's there's very very few women that
have that in common with men
you see some of these chicks that are
like you know on like the instagram or
you know maybe they get pulled onto joe
rogan or something like that and they
they like to hunt or they've got like a
bow hunters thing or
or a bow hunter's instagram or something
like that okay that might be interesting
but i still want a banger right like
i don't want to hang out with her to
shoot guns i want to hang out with her
because she's hot and i want to bang
right yeah so it's it's it's sex first
right okay you don't try to friend zone
yourself into women's lives it's a very
very bad approach that that that
leads many men down the wrong path and
they get super frustrated with it
just don't do it like straight up like
right here men and women can't be
friends
yeah yeah exactly i just like
i wanted to hear your advice maybe
to that trip because i don't know maybe
maybe she wants to get anything to made
no maybe listen if she wants to get
intimate text her right now and say i'm
horny i've got wood come over
see what she said seriously okay see
what she says
joshua joshua says straight up sorry to
say
but you're her tampon
okay well i didn't quite get that josh
uh you're you are there for emotional
validation for her
learn this lesson women have girlfriends
and boyfriends if you're not banging
you're her girlfriend don't think that
it's going to turn into intimacy by
taking this trip or by meeting her there
for this trip
it's not going to go well you're going
to get frustrated and i guarantee you
you're going to be very disappointed
when you see her banging chad when
you're sitting there
on the trip on the beach sipping on your
corona by yourself looking around
wondering where she's at
and she comes back to the the table or
the
lounge chair walking funny because he
because chad just rearranged her insides
don't fall for this nonsense okay yeah
i'm saying this because i actually care
like i'm not trying to beat you up here
but i feel like i actually have to come
down hard on you so you can hear me
no no really i know that that's your
intention but
uh yeah i think that maybe if we were
like
kind of dating and then she tells me to
travel that thing
will be different right but since we
have never been intermediate it's like
maybe it's not going to work yeah right
now and say
i'm horny i've got wood come over see
what she does
nice thank you so much richard have a
good one
be good
you